in recent times the meetings between the
US presidents and European leaders
they've become quite tense the NATO
summit which took place in early July of
2018 has been pretty good proof of that
and it's up some questions on the table
is Donald Trump right when criticizing
is European partners are the European
NATO countries taking advantage of the
United States Army and perhaps most
importantly should Europe have an army
well listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
if one thing has become very clearance
that Donald Trump isn't too fond of
these European leader meetings
I mean how bothersome it is to have to
meet with all these people I mean poor
old Trump if they were at least as fun
as vladimir putin or kim jeong-hoon i
mean any would be different right the
facts given is that the clash between
the US administration and most european
governments extends to virtually all
issues economy trade immigration and
defense NATO members must finally
contribute their fair share and meet
their financial obligations but 23 of
the 28 member nations are still not
paying what they should be paying and
what they're supposed to be paying for
their defense see the US president has
been criticizing NATO for years due to
the alleged lack of involvement of the
European partners in fact the u.s.
president has been saying things like
that for almost 20 years America has no
vital interest in Europe their conflicts
are not worth American lives pulling
back from Europe would save this country
millions of dollars annually Donald
Trump in 2000 of course it isn't just
about the tenants of the white house the
truth is that in recent decades the
differences between Europe and America
have expanded for example this baseball
vs. soccer and appreciation for cars
with gigantic engines one can tell where
the gas must be cheaper right and also
the way in which weapons are considered
in all fields even in defense yep the
Army and the military are very very
important issues in US politics but over
in Europe not so much and it's even
worse than not so much in fact these
perhaps even front-page issues and
they're certainly not very popular
perhaps that's why since the Cold War
into the military spending of European
countries that belonged to NATO has
collapsed in terms of GDP ranging from
something a little over three percent to
less than 1.5 in Europe military
spending it just doesn't sell and this
to viewers has greatly angered
Washington's politicians in recent years
and in this matter we're not only
talking about Donald Trump at all sober
ican bomber and George W Bush here on
visual politic in a previous video we
told you why it isn't such a good idea
for European country so you could spend
more money on weapons but hold on just a
minute
what if Washington was actually right
I'll listen up
what if Washington was right
here's a question for you and as I
always say please don't google it
because that's cheating do you know how
many soldiers the European NATO
countries have in total well I'll tell
you it's approximately 1.8 million
soldiers however this number only 30%
can be deployed in the case of a
conflict and only 50 to 100 thousand can
be deployed sustainably and for greater
lengths of time and folks in general the
European armies they've got many
operational problems yeah it's true they
do spend a lot of money but their
governments most of them don't really
care very much about the results we can
for example look at Germany a country
that in 2017 had a military budget of
approximately 45 billion dollars that is
it has one of the top ten largest
military budgets of any country while
despite being one of the countries with
the largest military budget a couple of
years ago a study by the consultancy
firm Kinsey revealed that almost 60% of
Germany's Eurofighter and Tornado
fighter aircrafts and 80% of their most
modern helicopters were not ready for
combat due to a lack of maintenance
updates and supplies at the end of 2017
a parliamentary investigation showed
quite a similar result not one of the
submarines and none of the 14 main
transport planes of the German air force
were even operational
not a single one and we're not even
exaggerating even a document from the
German Ministry of Defense warns that
the soldiers didn't have enough
protective vests winter clothes or
tenths to participate in any important
NATO mission and believe me it's not
just Germany for example during the war
in Libya despite being a relatively
small conflict just three weeks after
the attacks began the European air
forces began to run out of precision
weapons in other words governments spend
large amounts of money on weapons
programs and they've hired many soldiers
but that doesn't really matter when it
comes to the day-to-day operations and
that's how we end up with news like this
the Legion declares all-out war on
obesity the elite unit of the Spanish
infantry launches a plan to combat
obesity among its members but honestly
hold on because that's not the worst of
it
perhaps what annoys the US officers the
most are the rules with which some of
the European armies have entered combat
under NATO for example in Afghanistan
see many European governments don't want
to assume any kind of risk so they order
their military commanders to maintain
their soldiers away from the front in
the case of the Afghan campaign for
example US soldiers sharing testimonies
in which they were denied medical
evacuation by Europeans because they
were in a combat zone wasn't strange
listen to this ganna Stan year 2008 we
were returning from a mission when a
rocket hit the vehicle that was in front
of mine our Humvee was suddenly being
attacked by machine-gun fire of the 11
vehicles that entered the ambush area
four were left inoperative and a fifth
one was destroyed
one of our boys had died and a dozen
were wounded we were 6 hours away by car
from our base it was getting dark and
the Taliban were still attacking us when
we call to ask for a medical evacuation
they asked us if the landing area was
still hot we said yes we were being
attacked that moment of voice with a
foreign accent told me that their rules
prevented them from providing us
assistance he asked me if we could
secure the landing area or if we could
move minutes turned into hours the
Taliban continued attacking us then out
of nowhere a voice came up on the radio
it was American a couple of blackhawk
helicopters from a
totally different mission had heard our
help call the pilots deviated
immediately within 15 minutes they
landed and our wounded were evacuated
our superiors told us that the NATO
country who is responsible for medical
evacuations had a rule that prevented
them from intervening in still-hot areas
we were furious Elliot Ackerman a
veteran who served in the Afghanistan
Marine Special Operations Corps just a
second because this is really important
in Afghanistan alone nearly 900 European
soldiers have lost their lives we're
talking about political orders that
don't happen in all cases but which are
very common and know it's not a matter
of money it's a matter of commitment
every year the European NATO countries
spend almost 300 billion dollars that is
together they have the second largest
military budget after the United States
[Music]
in spite of this in Washington they want
European NATO countries to substantially
increase their military spending and
that's where the magical 2% of the GDP
figure appears
[Applause]
[Music]
the two-percent myth
as he made very clear at the last NATO
summit Donald Trump is furious according
to the vast majority of the countries of
the Atlantic Alliance they're late in
their quota payments check this out
many countries in NATO which we are
expected to defend are not only short of
their current commitment of 2% which is
low but are also delinquent for many
years and payments that have not been
made
well they reimburse the u.s. well one of
two is true neither he's saying this
because he has no idea or he's saying it
because he wants some electoral points
by of course fooling the voters because
let's be clear this entire late payments
thing has no point of reference see 2%
is a military spending objective from
each country for its own army it has
nothing to do with NATO payments or
anything like that that is if a country
spends less it doesn't owe anything to
NATO the United States or anyone else
for that matter but the fact is that in
2014 after a lot of pressure Barack
Obama managed to get the European NATO
countries to commit to substantially
increasing their military budgets to
reach two percent of their GDP by 2024
and precisely due to that commitments
from Europe is the region of the world
where military spending is increasing
the most check this out
[Applause]
yes you know that later Trump and
especially his supporters will say that
this was all thanks to him to his
magnificent negotiating skills however
even if military spending increases it
probably won't actually change anything
first this 2% figure it's a random
number which could be reached simply by
raising military salaries or cheating in
all kinds of other ways Greece for
example is one of the few countries that
complies with this and it spends 2.36
percent of its GDP but a large part of
that budget is used to pay for military
pensions and even most of their
investment in military equipment is
geared towards defence against Turkey
which is another NATO member country the
result of this well even though the
expenditure rule is apparently being
followed the Greek army brings little or
nothing to the organization's
capabilities but even though all of this
money could be used to really improve
the armies and of course without
political commitments it will never
happen not much will be achieved anyway
European countries will continue to
depend on the United States for force
deployments because each country on its
own wouldn't be able to afford to
maintain that kind of global deployments
intelligence and supply capabilities and
of course even that in Europe military
operations aren't popular
neither the political commitments and
other rules for entering combats
will actually change that is we would
have larger armies but at the moment of
truth very similar deficiencies but also
let's consider something else the Armed
Forces can perform four essential
functions deterrence intervention and
deployment occupation and cyber security
for none of these tasks is the current
European countries budget a hindrance
[Music]
to fight terrorism more quickly deploy
somewhere in the world and face a
special situation you don't really need
multiple aircraft carriers that is
redundant forces it's much more
important to be able to deploy quickly
and manage a conflict for example
there's the latest United States and
NATO wars in Afghanistan Iraq and Libya
in all of them their military victory
was simple but the post-war period it
was an absolute disaster preparing
forces to manage local conflicts and
using the country's different
institutions to train the national
forces not only the military but also
for the police trial courts prisons
power plants etc would probably have
been a great deal more useful at the end
of the day to viewer facing a conflict
requires a lot of things and not always
the same ones the threats we face today
don't require aircraft carriers or
fighter bombers they require agility
Europe doesn't need to spend more it
spends a lot it just needs to spend
better and that's where the idea of the
European army emerged
[Music]
pesco a European army in December of
2017 the European Union launched the
pesco program the permanent structured
cooperation its objective while that
would be coordinating the countries that
participate in the program in terms of
security acquisition of war materials
and joint defense and peace operations
in other words to begin integrating the
various Armed Forces the program is
still in a very incipient phase and
isn't considered the equivalent of a
European army yet however this could be
the best solution to all their problems
[Music]
the 25 countries that make up the pesco
program by integrating their armies
their weapons purchases their training
and even by sharing resources could mean
that Europe even while spending the last
would have a modern well-equipped army
with great deployment capabilities after
all if a country like Spain spends a
fortune buying leopard 2 tanks which as
happens and in practice due to a lack of
means to deploy them only uses them to
defend against Portugal they've made a
totally unnecessary expense wouldn't you
agree
folks today the risks and challenges
steg global so I sincerely believe that
Europe needs more integration to do
things better and seek to complete the
US military's contributions within the
NATO framework but it's not achieved by
spending more also almost three hundred
billion dollars a year it should be more
than enough but now it's your 10 do you
think Europe should develop its own army
well leave your answer in the comments
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos don't forget to check
out our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast as well they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine also
of course this channel is made possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please do consider joining
them and supporting us in our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you